and as far as tablets are concerned yes
you could make some okay images of your
work very quickly like we did here
here's the music box which you've seen
before this one was made with the tablet
but always keep in mind that the file
size is not even close to what we get
with a full size camera and it's
certainly not as convenient as a camera
phone in my opinion but i thought i'd
show you something i was playing around
with a while ago and here's an image i
made of an area of a device and we could
actually see 30 micron structures I made
the images with a tablet it's
considerably cropped from the full image
now here's a setup I put the tablets
camera on selfie mode that is using the
front camera the idea is that you can
see exactly what the camera is seeing
and so that you could make adjustments
to the setup in real time here's the
jeweler's lens that I placed over the
camera in the tablet and here's the
setup from another angle let's zoom in
so that you see how it looks so
basically I am making a microscopic
image with this setup you can adjust the
distance of the lens from the device by
using different wooden blocks for
example there are a number of companies
selling supposedly microscopic lenses
would you attached to your phone or
tablet but I'm not convinced the quality
of the optics is what we want here we
see some very fine detail because of the
quality of the lens but unfortunately
the file size as we said is pretty low
but that is improving rapidly so this
could be a quick way of sharing your
work with your colleagues through emails
for example it's just something to think
about